cool thing about how the u.s tax code  works is that loans are never treated as  income but they are spendable money that  you can consume and use for example if i  continue to plow all of my money into  assets that earn while i sleep if they  continue to grow and they are growing  tax free then the growth that is  tax-free i can realize by taking loans  against those things and i can use those  loans to live my life and as long as the  loans that i'm taking are less than the  growth of my assets then i can use all  of that growth continue to let it  compound tax free for the rest of my  life and live off the loans and when i  die they can they can rectify my account  these are the strategies of the people  who are ultra wealthy